you may have heard the news that's right
I'm broke but thanks to many fellow
Patriots we managed to gather $4,000 to
help myself although for legal reasons I
couldn't keep any of the money which
means I'm back on square zero
I got nothing nada Enya quit so what do
you do when all hope fails what do you
do before I was pretty tight that's
right
selling hot dogs a lot of you may have
known this some of you may have not but
before I did YouTube I sold hot dogs
it is in fact my specialty it's what the
best thing I an only thing I know
besides screaming and acting like a
[ __ ] only internet
[Music]
well windy for a grouse I would say
and matures I would say back
you got a grill like this you gotta have
balls
[Music]
females will they'll be contaminate
you like it
get get
action
I'm done
thank you I'm done
what tell now do you want to enough
oh oh it's a wonderful day to do what
will you do
lady one on down maybe one out no no
one's on now right shut no half-dog man
you're looking hungry
dinnertime I feel really bad that
nobody's buying
Felix his computer is hot dogs so
there's a humor him and my hot dog
[Applause]
I'm Bion
[Music]
okay thank you
so how's the business going oh and no
it's is not a bit I mean just doing it
it's like a full-time thing now it's a
hobby yeah yeah oh wait actually PJ yeah
I have a sense you're a loyal customer
loyal because you get my special hot dog
oh yeah okay
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe yeah like poisonous toad as a lamb
poisonous to sleep can I borrow your put
your poisonous flames it's a sexual
investment and I put it back where it
belongs
for the VIPs here you go peeking hey
thanks man
wow you really did it with the catch
over to catch up there thanks man I
appreciate appreciate we're worried
can you leave a good review yes best
review all right thank you good luck
enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
enough
very much will be happy now I have to
sell my most prized possession
Mike my golden plaque
this is the real goal the pike is in my
life
hi bike okay cool great huh thank you I
give you five oh thank you very much I
appreciate it
serious thank you very much thank you
very much thanks Felix have a good way I
got 5 pounds if the new bill is to I
really like these this is great it's
looking going
he actually boy
[Music]